I'm speaking to you at what I know is an
increasingly challenging time a time of
disruption in the life of our country a
disruption that has brought grief to
some financial difficulties too many and
enormous changes to the daily lives of
us all I want to thank everyone on the
NHS front line as well as care workers
and there's carrying out two central
roles who selflessly continue their
day-to-day duties outside the home in
support of us all
I'm sure the nation will join me in
assuring you that what you do is
appreciated and every hour of your hard
work brings us closer to a return to
more normal times I also want to thank
those of you who are staying at home
thereby helping to protect the
vulnerable and sparing many families the
pain already felt by those who have lost
loved ones together we are tackling this
disease and I want to reassure you that
if we remain united and resolute then we
will overcome it I hope in the years to
come everyone will be able to take pride
in how they responded to this challenge
and those who come after us will say the
britons of this generation were as
strong as any that the attributes of
self-discipline of quiet good-humoured
resolve and a fellow feeling still
characterized this country the pride in
who we are is not a part of our past it
defines our present and our future
[Applause]
the moments when the United Kingdom has
come together to applaud its care and
essential workers will be remembered as
an expression of our national spirit and
it's symbol will be the rainbows drawn
by children across the Commonwealth and
around the world we have seen
heartwarming stories of people coming
together to help others be it through
delivering food parcels and medicines
checking on neighbors or converting
businesses to help the relief effort and
those self isolating may at times be
hard many people of all faiths and of
none are discovering that it presents an
opportunity to slow down pause and
reflect in prayer or meditation it
reminds me of the very first broadcast I
made in 1940 helped were my sister we as
children spoke from here at Windsor two
children who had been evacuated from
their homes and sent away for their own
safety today once again many will feel a
painful sense of separation from their
loved ones
but now as then we know deep down that
it is the right thing to do while we
have faced challenges before this one is
different this time we join with all
nations across the globe in a common
endeavour using the great advances of
science and our instinctive compassion
to heal we will succeed and that success
will belong to every one of us we should
take comfort that while we may have more
still to endure better days will return
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again we will
meet again but for now I send my
and warmest good wishes to all